so first up we have Michael B Jordan in
the boxing movie Creed you know he's
great a great performer great actor
great looking guy my only question is is
he too young exactly I mean are we
really gonna give such a grand that she
meant to somebody with such a modest
body of work
Oscar should go to someone who's been
tested you know someone who's seasoned
someone who's ever Lord yes yes yes yeah
I mean you look at her and you think
warmth talent safety something that I
didn't feel from ma Jordan especially
safety yeah so I think we're all in
agreement Jennifer Lawrence the best
actress yeah right moving right along we
have a straight out of Compton for a
Best Picture am I saying that right
Compton Wow
Justin ah inspiring body of women I
remember sitting there in the theater
thinking that but you know it also felt
a little short for me I just couldn't
connect something just just wasn't
believable you know I agree I mean the
point of a film like this is to convey
the poetry of a journey well we're
talking about journeys we may as well
mention Matt Damon's journey from Mars I
mean you can drive from Compton to
Hollywood a couple times in an afternoon
but try going from Compton to Mars more
than once how many potatoes that entire
film just portrays such a harsh
environment where the average person
would have fallen victim but he was able
to overcome this you know Matt Damon
seems like someone who could just grab a
beer with you know like a friend her
husband
okay well I think we're all in agreement
but we're nominating the Martian for
Best Picture yes okay let's see what
else oh oh of course
beasts of no nation actor Abraham octa
for the best leading role you know I
loved him in the wire this time around
he just felt a little bit incorrect
I love you thumper chip cookies but just
tastes a little off about them they're
too chocolatey right and he I try to eat
around the chocolate chips pretend
they're not even there